playing private Leonard Lawrence and
full metal jacket it's so intense those
moments and I just was was any of that
improvised what happened was he he you
know he did he was a drill instructor in
real life you know for many years after
he you know this guy did three tours in
Vietnam he went back twice but he has so
he had an abundance uh from being a
drill instructor and being around in
that life his whole life in that world
this whole life he had abundance of
things to say but Stanley so he would he
would just say them spurt them out and
Stanley would then typed them all out
word for word but then Lee would have to
then do them every time so he kind of
dug his own grave and that was my first
film so like I didn't know any different
but no there was no improvising but you
know so in a way he was spitting out
improvisations but not when the camera
was rolling